Europe is a continent that to my account
has 41 currently active territorial
disputes between different countries
going on within it ranging from mild to
moderate to Serious levels of
controversy to start this video off
we're going to go through the list of
Europe's mild disputes first before
moving on to the more serious ones which
are disputes that don't involve any
actually inhabited territories involve
very small amounts of essentially
inconsequential territory and are in
most of these cases so small scale and
low-key that most of the residents in
the countries involved aren't even aware
that the disputes even exist in the
first place place the first of these
more mild and arguably goofy disputes is
between France and Italy and concerns
who between them actually owns the
summit of Mont Blanc the highest
mountain in the Alps and the highest
point located anywhere in Europe outside
of the Caucasus mountain range when you
look closely at the French Italian
border here that runs along the crest of
the mountains you'll notice these two
small areas that are in dispute between
them the Italian claimed border follows
the natural Watershed here and splits
the summit of Western Europe's highest
mountain evenly between them while the
French claimed border simply deviates
ever so slightly from the natural
Watershed to incorporate the entire
Summit of Mont Blanc within France
instead thus enabling France to insist
on sole ownership of the mountain Summit
and Western Europe's highest peak
without sharing it with the Italians
Italy insists that the 1860 Treaty of
Turin signed between France and the
kingdom of Sardinia in which France
annexed the duchy of seavoy established
the modern border between France and
Italy after Italy was unified the
following year in 1861 but then for
years later in 1865 the Italians alleg
that France moved their idea of the
border on the mountain unilaterally so
as to fully incorporate the summit into
French territory which Italy has never
accepted and continually rejected for
nearly the past 160 years now leading to
the current state of small but prideful
territorial disputes between them
Germany is a country that historically
had many territorial disputes all
throughout Europe but today really only
has two thankfully very minor disputes
the first of which is with the
Netherlands here in the Estuary of the M
River the bay here between the
Netherlands and Germany is known as the
dollart and it is fully on the western
side of the M River Germany legally
regards the maritime border between them
here in the dollar Bay as running from
the recognized land border here entirely
along the Left Bank of the M River
essentially following the Dutch
Shoreline out into the North Sea the
Netherlands maintains a different legal
view however and counter insists that
the maritime border between them here
follows the river thwag or in other
words the Center Line that follows the
lowest elevation within the rivers
Valley which leaves a narrow Maritime
area between their claims that both
countries maintain an open dispute over
at a highlevel meeting in 2014 the
foreign Ministers of Germany and the
Netherlands finally meant to settle this
long running and hotly contentious
dispute once and for all and they
basically just agreed to disagree they
agreed that the maritime border here
between them would simply remain
ambiguous and undefined with each side
sharing a mutual legal responsibility
over the area instead of actually coming
up with any hard definitions meaning
that the disputed border here will
likely remain for the foreseeable future
and Germany's other active ongoing
territorial dispute today is somehow
even less controversial than that here
in the far Southwest of Germany lies
Lake constant a large Alpine Lake where
the borders of Germany Austria and
Switzerland all converge at now weirdly
when you look at this Lake in Google
Maps you'll notice that the borders of
all three of these countries immediately
end the moment they reach the Lakes
Shoreline as opposed to the borders
shown that crisscross other lakes in the
region nearby like Lake Geneva and Lake
maior on Lake constant the borders are
shown to end the moment the borders
reach the lake because the lake itself
is the subject of a territorial dispute
Austria's legal position is that the
entire lake is 100% jointly co-owned and
shared by all three of the countries
around it making the whole lake a sort
of condominium with free and equal
access to all three countries around it
s land however doesn't agree with his
Viewpoint owing to the fact that Austria
controls the smallest amount of
Coastline on the lake and so they argue
instead that the international borders
between all three countries here run
down the center line of the lake with
Switzerland and Germany controlling most
of the lake and Austria limited to only
a sliver of it around their immediate
Coastline meanwhile Germany maintains no
official legal opinion on the borders in
the lake at all and takes a deliberately
neutral stance between the differing
positions of Austria and Switzerland
leaving the lake behind as a very
lowlevel controversy between all three
the next minor dispute in Europe is over
on the other side of the continent and
concerns the status of an island called
K Island between Ukraine and Romania
making up Ukraine's much much much lower
intensity territorial dispute with a
country that begins with R the problem
here is that K island is a relatively
new land mass that only began forming
naturally in the early 2000s in the
Black Sea right at the mouth of the danu
river that mostly forms the border
between Ukraine and Romania this border
here has long been the established
border between the two states that was
agreed upon between the Soviet Union and
Romania in 1948 and then reaged upon
again after Ukraine became independent
with the Romanian Ukrainian border
Treaty of 1997 unfortunately as K Island
began forming shortly after that treaty
in the early 2000s the international
border cut across the northern tip of
the island which led the ukrainians to
unilaterally alter their interpretation
of the Border in 2010 to fully Encompass
the new island within Ukrainian
territory which Romanian authorities
have objected to ever since but since
the island is unin inited Tiny and has
barely even existed for more than 20
years hardly anybody really cares about
it moving on another tiny Island that a
bunch of countries in Europe maintain a
dispute over is up here in the North
Atlantic called rockle and as its name
sort of implies it's really less of an
island and more of just a big rock in
the middle of the ocean with the legal
status of a rock that's uninhabitable no
State can really claim it as an island
and benefit from the large Maritime e
area that would normally go along with
it rockol is indisputably located with
within the E of the UK but it's also
located in a geographically weird area
where the ezs of Ireland Iceland and
Denmark by way of the Danish own Pharaoh
Islands all roughly converge at the
dispute here around rockle therefore
isn't so much over the maritime
boundaries above the sea but on the
access to the ocean floor beneath the
sea on the continental shelf because all
four of these countries technically
claim the sea floor beneath rockol as a
natural extension of their Continental
shelves the ownership of the continental
shelf rights around rockol are valuable
because they would enable whichever
State who owns them the exclusive rights
to harvest any resources that could
potentially be located down their own
the seaf Flor like oil and gas and so
it's the ownership of these kinds of
Rights around little Rockall that all
four of these European countries dispute
to this day and now we're going to dip
our toes into the area of Europe with
the highest concentration of ongoing
territorial disputes the Balkans one of
the more minor territorial disputes here
at the moment concerns Croatia and
Montenegro who despite only bordering
each other with a tiny border length of
just 25 km have still managed to fit in
a dispute there anyway the issue between
them here stems over the status of the
small prevlaka peninsula here the
southernmost point of Croatia that
strategically juts out into the entrance
of the moneger known Bay of cotor during
the breakup of Yugoslavia in the 1990s
the Serbian and monan forces attempted
to capture the prevlaka peninsula from
Croatia along with the rest of the
Adriatic Coastline here up to the
important city of dubnik which was put
to sieged by them for months between
1991 and 1992 with the then montenegrin
prime minister asserting that dubnik was
rightfully montenegrin by the end of
1992 however the Croatian Army had
managed to break the siege of deenik and
recaptured the whole Coastline including
the Strategic prevlaka Peninsula which
then led to the Croatian and
montenegrian sides mutually agreeing on
keeping the prevlaka peninsula a
demilitarized zone and led to un
Security Council resolution 779 which
affirmed the demilitarized status of the
Paka Peninsula and placed a un
peacekeeping Force there to basically
keep the peninsula as a un buffer zone
area between them at the end of 2002 a
decade later the UN mandated
peacekeeping mission on the peninsula
ended and it was fully returned back to
Croatia again which led to Croatia and
Montenegro signing what was intended to
only be a temporary arrangement in
regards to the Handover this supposedly
temporary agreement recognized the
return of the peninsula to Croatia but
also stipulated that in order to
maintain the peninsula's demilitarized
status going forward the sea Bay on the
Eastern side of the peninsula up to the
Croatian border was to remain strictly
off limits as a sort of no man Zone with
unrecognized territorial claims and
decades later now that temporary
agreement has continued remaining
theoretically in force even after both
Croatia and Montenegro have joined the
NATO alliance with Montenegro still not
recognizing Croatia's territorial Waters
in The Bay here and that's far from the
only Maritime dispute that Croatia has
gotten itself involved Den it's pretty
well known by most geography Geeks that
Croatia almost completely landlock
Bosnia and Herz Goa by its control of
virtually the entire Northeastern
Adriatic Coastline with the sole
exception of this tiny Corridor that's
fewer than 5 km wide centered on the
Bosnian Port of newe that grants Bosnian
heroa its only tiny access out to the
Sea the corridor in newe also separates
Croatian territory into two separate
halves with a northern Mainland and a
southern semi exclave centered around
the city of duik there isn't any part of
these borders that is openly in dispute
today but between 2018 and 2022 the
croatians spent 420 million euros
constructing a major Bridge Project here
that they called the piaac bridge which
finally linked up their two disconnected
halves by land and enabled croatians for
the first ever time to drive over land
between them without having to pass
through Bosnian territory first the
bridge has also been very deeply
controversial within Bosnian herova
however because it was built directly
across the channel of their only sea
access to the global ocean contributing
to their sense of being landlocked by
Croatia even further ktia agreed to
build the bridge to a height of 55 M
which enables all but the absolute
biggest of container and cruise ships to
continue passing under the bridge and
accessing the Bosnian port and new but
several Bosnian officials have still
noted that the Bridge's existence will
deny the port and new from ever being
able to upgrade itself to handle those
kinds of huge container and cruise ships
in the future and so the the Bosnian
government's official position is that
the bridge was unilaterally constructed
by the croatians over what they regard
as international waters while the
Croatian perspective is that they built
the bridge fully within Croatia's own
territorial Waters and that they
therefore didn't need to seek out the
Bosnian government's approval in order
to do it and that the bridge still
allows all pre-existing Bosnian Maritime
shipping to continue anyway effectively
leading to a kind of territorial dispute
where the Bosnian government rejects to
the existence of Croatia's Bridge here
rather than any territory and yet
Croatia maintains yet another fairly
minor territorial dispute with another
one of their neighbors Serbia right here
at about 14 different individual
locations across their border that
generally follows along the danu river
the dispute here stems from Serbia and
Croatia's different interpretations of
where the border between them along the
danu should actually be placed at Serbia
legally regards the thwg of the danu
Valley and the center line of the river
as it currently flows today to be the
border between them while Croatia
differs from this View and insists on
the border being exactly as it was back
in the 19th century that follows the
center line of the danu river as it used
to historically flow before the Advent
of hydrotechnical engineering Works
altered the Dan's course to what it
currently looks like now these
differences in opinion between them have
left around 140 square kmers of land
territory across 14 separate areas along
the danu an open dispute between them
which is nearly the same size as the
micro state of lonstein but since nobody
seemingly actually lives in any of these
disputed territories it doesn't rise up
to a more serious dispute as it
currently stands now Serbia controls
most of the territories that are in
dispute with all 10 of these yellow
highlighted areas east of the current
flow of the danu claimed by Croatia but
controlled by Serbia meanwhile because
Croatia claims the Border as the
historical flow of the danu River from
the 19th century it has led to an
interesting situation where there are
three small territories west of the
current flow of the danu river that cro
I does not legally claim and insists
their Serbian instead but which Serbia
Rejects and insists their Croatian which
means that these three small pockets of
land along the danu are all currently
unclaimed By Any Nation on Earth and
represent the only currently unclaimed
lands in Europe this situation led to an
eccentric Czech libertarian politician
named vit yeda to begin claiming the
largest piece of unclaimed land here
about the same size as Gibralter for his
self- declared Free Republic of Li land
and he has reportedly been arrested by
Croatian authorities multiple times for
attempting to enter the land but as it
has stood for decades now Croatia cannot
claim these three small territories west
of the danu without giving up its bigger
and more important claims to the larger
territories east of the river and since
Serbia won't ever claim them either
they're likely to remain in a weird
legal Gray Zone for the foreseeable
future another weird sort of gry zone
territory of the Balkans can be found
here a small exclave of Bosnian
territory known as rudo home to around
173 people who are completely surrounded
by Serbia weirdly the Border here only
appears on maps like Google and apple
and there aren't any border crossings or
markings or checkpoints to even suggest
that a border even exists there at all
on the map even though the territory is
universally recognized as belonging to
Bosnia and Herzegovina and all of its
residents reportedly even pay their
taxes to the government of bosnan and
Herzegovina all of the day-to-day
administration of the territory is
handled by the Serbian government
instead blurring the line here between
whether or not the small territory is
recognized as Bosnian or Serbian and
it's not even the only territory in
Europe that's like this where the
residents have a blurry sense of what
country they might belong to over in the
Iberian Peninsula there's this
relatively small territory known as
olivenza it's about 430 sare km in area
larger than Malta and home to around
12,000 residents and administered by
Spain but legally disputed in its
entirety by neighboring Portugal as well
the history of this dispute goes a ways
back but basically ienzo is continually
under Portuguese rule for centuries ever
since they took it over from the crown
of Castile all the way back in the year
1297 half a millennium later in 1801
however things changed when the Spanish
invaded Portugal and then forced the
Portuguese to seed over olivenza to them
in the 1801 Tradio BOS which included an
article that explained that the treaty
would be cancelled if any of its other
articles rules were violated such as
either Portugal or Spain attacking each
other again in the future so then just 6
years later in 1807 Spain and Napoleonic
France jointly invaded Portugal again
which Portugal claims canceled out the
previous 1801 Treaty of BOS that seeded
over aliv Venza further article 105 of
the later Treaty of Vienna that laid out
the borders of Europe after Napoleon's
overthrow which Spain signed in 1817
compelled Spain to return olivenza back
to Portugal again but then for more than
200 years since then Spain just kind of
never did that and has just kept holding
on to aliv Venza anyway arguing that
they felt that the treaty language
didn't make their return of olivenza
explicitly mandatory since then Portugal
has never made a formal claim to the
territory of alenza which is why it's
not marked as a disputed territory in
Google Maps but Portugal has also never
directly acknowledged Spain's
sovereignty over Al ienza either making
it in theory a sort of gry zone
territory Portuguese military Maps as
recently as 2013 still do not show a
border that separates olivenza from
Portugal while it also seems that the
dispute over the territory is so lowkey
that most Spanish citizens aren't even
aware that it even exists at all and
it's been a fairly moot point anyway
since Spain and Portugal have each been
in the EU for decades now so it's not
really a very serious issue but Spain's
continued control over aliv Venza for
centuries despite signing treaties to
give it back will seem fairly
hypocritical when it comes to Spain's
other territorial dispute in Europe over
Gibralter which takes us into the more
moderate levels of territorial disputes
in Europe that actually involve larger
numbers of people or more serious
National strategic interests jalter is a
British overseas territory in city at
the southern tip of the Iberian
Peninsula that while small is very
densely populated with around 34,000
people today who are all British
citizens jalter was first captured by
the British from Spain more than three
centuries ago back in 1704 during the
war of the Spanish succession which led
Spain to agree on seeding jalter to the
UK under the terms of the 17713 Treaty
of utre that ended that war Spain then
attempted to recapture jalter by force
with a Siege in 1727 and another very
long Siege between 1779 and 1783 during
the American Revolutionary War neither
of which were successful and which
resulted in subsequent treaties in 1729
and 1783 that all affirmed Burton's
continued sovereignty over jalter the
issue then remained fairly dormant for
nearly another two centuries until
Spain's dictator Francisco Franco
reopened Spain's territorial claims to
jalter again in the 1960s which have
generally continued through to the
present day in theory the Spanish
government has sought to return the
whole of Gibralter back to their country
through diplomacy since the Franco era
of the 60s but Spain hasn't ever claimed
the entirety of jalter's territory
throughout this process
instead Spain has based its current
territorial claims to jalter on the
exact language used within the original
17713 Treaty of utra that seeded the
territory over to Britain which they
argue covered only the Fortified
perimeter of the town of jalter as it
existed back at that time which followed
this line immediately to the north of
the geographic Rock of jalter Spain
argues that none of the territory to the
north of this line was ever agreed to be
seated over to Britain by the Treaty of
utr and argues that over the centuries
since then the British gradually
expanded their area of control in jalter
North across the ismus that connects
jalter to the Spanish mainland that
formed the current deao border this has
led to a situation where Spain today as
of 2024 formally claims this amount of
territory in Northern jalter between
where the current border is and the
boundary Spain claims existed back in
17133 which notably includes the entire
chalter airport and the residences of
around 4,200 people who live within
jalter's Northern District a claim that
buron rejects on the grounds that
basically they've continually controlled
this land for centuries now so it may as
well stay British today which is also
basically the same argument that Spain
uses for its continued control of alenza
moreover Spain also insists that Bran's
ownership over the rest of jalter does
not confer with it any usual territorial
Waters that would be granted under
international law Spain insists that
Bron's only territorial Waters around
jalter are extremely limited to being
immediately within the port of jalter
and no further while the UK insists on
their usual territorial Waters around
jalter that would be granted under
International maritime law which leads
to all of these Waters around jalter
being disputed between the UK and Spain
as well and with both of these
Territorial and Maritime disputes around
jalter remaining active Spain has spent
decades attempting to negotiate with the
UK on getting back the rest of jalter as
well Spain's argument has been
historically based on two points that
Britain's control of jalter violates
Spain's territorial integrity and that
jalter's population of British citizens
today are settlers and a product of
British colonialism which is why Spain
refuses to consider the interests or
opinions of any of jalter's residents
today and insists on negotiating the
status of the territory exclusively with
the UK government itself Britain's
perspective meanwhile is based on the
principle of self-determination for the
32 residents of jalter today who time
and time again have shown in referendums
and votes that they overwhelmingly
prefer to remain a part of the UK and
the British government refuses to
negotiate with Spain on the issue
without the inclusion and representation
of the jalter government as an equal
party and bernon has consistently
rejected all of Spain's various attempts
to negotiate on jalter status for
decades now the dispute has also gotten
even more controversial since 2020 when
the UK left the European Union which
took jalter along with it which
established a more firm land border
crossing between the EU and the UK all
of which elevates the jalter dispute to
something a bit more moderate in
intensity next up we're going back to
Croatia again because oh man if you
thought Croatia was done with its border
disputes or blocking its neighbors
access to the ocean you were very wrong
in addition to their disputes with
Montenegro Serbia and Bosnian
Herzegovina Croatia's other modern
territorial dispute is with Slovenia and
is Ed on this little sliver of disputed
land between them near to the Gulf of
puran the Croatian claim here is that
the Border follows the course of the
dragonia river as it flows today while
the Slovenian claim is that the Border
runs just a bit further to the Southwest
along the historical boundaries between
them that used to exist in the 19th
century and a claim that will sound
familiar to the argument that Croatia
itself makes with Serbia along their
border that follows the danub river the
result is a small narrow strip of
disputed land between Croatia and
Slovenia in the middle of their claims
that includes a few houses and farms and
notably the casino hotel Mulino a luxury
five-star hotel and casino with hundreds
of highly rated Google reviews whose
website claims is located within Croatia
but whose entire property is marked as
being disputed by Slovenia in Google
Maps the land dispute itself isn't
extremely controversial but the maritime
dispute that it causes in the nearby
Gulf of puran certainly is because of
their different interpretations of where
the border on land lies Croatia claims
that the maritime border extends from
the mouth of the dragonia river across
the center of the Gulf of purin dividing
the gulf evenly between them and
Slovenia which happens to restrict
slovenia's territorial Waters to just
this narrow inlet immediately around
their own small Coastline and which also
blocks off slovenia's direct access to
international waters Slovenia meanwhile
counter insists that the maritime border
actually follows their land claim along
the entire southern coast of the Bay of
Pian to the cape here and then extends
out to about here in order to Grant
Slovenia direct access to international
waters without the meaning to pass
through Croatian or Italian territorial
Waters first and which also places the
entire Gulf of pan within the claimed
territorial Waters of Slovenia this
situation led to a hotly contested area
of disputed Waters between them that got
so contentious Slovenia actually
threatened to block Croatia's accession
into the year European Union for years
over it until they agreed on resolving
it in 2011 both Croatia and Slovenia
finally agree that they would submit the
dispute to the un's permanent Court of
arbitration to reach a final decision
and Slovenia ended its blockade of
Croatia's membership into the European
Union leading to Croatia joining the EU
in
2013 but then several years later in
2017 the permanent Court of arbitration
issued its final ruling on the disputed
border that looked like like this
essentially drawing the maritime Border
in between Croatia and slovenia's
respective claims and connecting
Slovenian territorial Waters to a
neutral Corridor through which Croatia
would have to Grant Universal passage to
Slovenia through in order to Grant
Slovenia uninterrupted access to
international waters the Slovenian
government hailed the agreement and
accepted the ruling but the Croatian
government immediately refused it and
stated that it wouldn't accept the
results based on their allegations the
Slovenian government officials were
improperly contact with the members of
the un's arbitration court before the
ruling was announced and their assertion
that the ruling was biased towards a pro
Slovenian outcome as a result which
leaves the waters in the Gulf appearing
in the land area along the dragonia
river disputed between Croatia and
Slovenia to this day keeping us in the
Balkans for now another long running
dispute has to do with North Macedonia
not with any of the country's territory
but with the very name that the country
chooses to call Itself by for decades
after gaining its dependence from
Yugoslavia in 1991 this country
officially referred to itself as the
Republic of Macedonia or just Macedonia
for short which has triggered a long
running dispute with neighboring Greece
who strongly objected to their use of
the label Macedonia the dispute arose
from the historical ambiguities around
the creation of the Socialist Republic
of Macedonia during the Yugoslav era the
emergence of a separate South Slavic
Macedonian ethnic identity throughout
the 20th century the existence of the
the ancient Greek Kingdom of Macedon and
the Contemporary geographic region of
Macedonia within Greece where a
significant number of ethnic Greeks
identify as macedonians and view
themselves as being completely different
from the south Slavic people who
identify as ethnic macedonians because
of these complexities Greece long argued
that without a geographical qualifier
like North Macedonia the state of
Macedonia could theoretically maintain
territorial claims to the whole
contemporary region of Macedonia
including territory in Greece Bulgaria
and Albania while they further accus the
macedonians of appropriating Greek
culture and symbols like Alexander the
Great in order to even join the United
Nations in 1993 Greece essentially
forced the country to adopt the
provisional name of the Former Yugoslav
Republic of Macedonia or the
fyrom instead of the Republic of
Macedonia name that I prefer to use
while gree continually blocked the
country's admission into either the EU
or NATO until the whole country would
agree on changing its name and for
decades they refused to consider
changing their name and this diplomatic
deadlock continued all the way up until
2018 when the two sides finally agreed
on a compromise wherein Macedonia would
formally change their name to North
Macedonia and Greece would drop their
blockages of the country into the EU and
nato in exchange the following year in
2019 Macedonia formally changed its name
to North Macedonia and in 2020 the
country was finally admitted into NATO
but that wasn't exactly the end of the
dispute the most recent election in
North Macedonia in 2024 delivered a new
nationalist candidate to the presidency
who immediately caused a diplomatic row
with Greece when during her inauguration
speech she deliberately referred to the
country by the old name of just
Macedonia again then in June of 2024 the
new nationalist North Macedonian prime
minister repeatedly referred to the
country as just Macedonia during his
speech to the country's Parliament and
blatantly said that he referred to the
new name of North Macedonia as a
shameful capitulation all of this has
led to the Greek government to recently
say that they don't believe the north
Macedonian government is serious about
the name change and that they'll go
right back to blocking the country's
accession into the European Union until
they're satisfied that they're actually
taking the name change more seriously
which makes it appear that the long
running dispute over this country is
name hasn't yet
ended and this gets us into the final
category of disputed territories and
borders in Europe the serious disputes
that involve major areas of land core
strategic interests Andor very large
numbers of people that actually have a
potential to escalate into conflict or
even outright war or in which active
Wars are already being fought over them
the first such territory in this final
list of serious disputes in Europe Keeps
Us in the Balkans and concerns the
status of Kosovo which depending on who
you ask at the present is either a fully
independent country or a rebellious
province of Serbia a serious dispute
that involves nearly 11,000 square kilm
of territory and nearly 1.6 million
people who live there Kosovo used to be
an autonomous province of Serbia for
decades throughout the Yugoslav ERA with
a large population of both ethnic
albanians and serbs with internal
Yugoslav demographic data from the 1950s
and 60s showing that albanians
constituted around 65% of the population
back then and serbs and montenegrin
around another 25% but during
yugoslavia's collapse in the 1990s the
Nationalist government of Serbia headed
by sladon mosovich began suppressing and
eliminating kosovo's former autonomy
which led to the emergence of the
Albanian dominated Kosovo Liberation
Army or klaa began waging an armed
Insurgency against the Serbian
government in Kosovo after 1996 that
sought kosovo's outright Independence
through Force violence in Kosovo between
the K and the Serbian government
continued to escalate until 1998 when
the building tension exploded into a
full-scale war in the territory that
eventually included the Serbian
government's attempt to ethnically
cleanse Kosovo of hundreds of thousands
of its Albanian residents and NATO's
decision to intervene against Serbia
militarily in 1999 then included a
bombing campaign that eventually
compelled the Serbian Army to withdraw
from Kosovo and led to tens of thousands
of of NATO troops entering into Kosovo
in their place as either peacekeepers or
occupiers depending on your perspective
the 1998 to 99 War dramatically shifted
kosovo's internal demographics more than
13,000 people were killed during the
Kosovo war and around 850,000 albanians
have been forcefully expelled from
Kosovo at gunpoint by the Serbian Army
and paramilitaries and NATO facilitated
most of their return to their territory
in the aftermath of 1999 while harsh
reprisal attacks from the albanians on
the Serb community in Kosovo led to the
Exodus of around 200,000 serbs from
Kosovo as refugees into the rest of
Serbia in the immediate aftermath which
nearly eliminated kosovo's large Serb
minority and led to Kosovo being over
90% ethnically Albanian today which some
have argued represented another ethnic
cleansing of kosovo's ser population
Kosovo was then placed under a
transitional un Administration that
authorized NATO to maintain its
peacekeeping force in the territory and
then nearly a decade later in 2008 Koso
unilaterally declared its independence
from Serbia which has remained
unrecognized by the Serbian government
to this day and is deeply contentious
with nobody so far having managed to
reach a diplomatic solution to the
dispute some recent negotiations to
finally reach some solution have
included Kosovo granting its remaining
serve population of around 100,000 in
the north their full autonomy within
Koso in exchange for legal recognition
of independence from Serbia or a
Territorial and population exchange
scheme where Kosovo would seed its
remaining sir majority areas in the
north to Serbia in exchange for Serbia
seeding some Albanian majority areas in
the East over to Kosovo and extending
its legal recognition of kosovo's
Independence but so far neither of these
ideas have been implemented and they
each have their various problems and so
no solution has yet been reached reached
but since kosovo's 2008 Independence
declaration around 104 UN member states
have chosen to legally recognize
kosovo's Independence including the
United States and most of its allies in
Europe and the Pacific while Russia and
China along with the other bricks
members India Brazil South Africa and
Iran in addition to Serbia have all
chosen to take Serbia's side in the
dispute and have rejected kosovo's
Independence leading to kosovo's legal
status being hotly contentious on the
international stage as well
interestingly there are even several EU
and NATO countries that reject kosovo's
Independence as well including Spain
Slovakia Romania and Greece Spain
rejects kosovo's Independence out of
fear of the precedent kosovo's
unilateral Independence declaration
might set for Catalonia while Slovakia
and Romania reject kosovo's Independence
out of a similar fear of the precedent
it could set for their own large
Hungarian minorities and Greece rejects
kosovo's Independence out of the fear of
the president it could set for the next
series serious territorial dispute in
Europe in Cyprus Cyprus is an island in
the Eastern Mediterranean that is these
days de facto divided between three
different entities the ethnically Greek
majority Republic of Cyprus in the South
the ethnically Turkish majority Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus or trnc in
the north and two Sovereign British
military bases in the South and the East
while the Greek majority Republic of
Cypress claims all of the territory on
the island that's controlled by the trnc
and considers it all as legally occupied
this situation arose shortly after
Cyprus was granted its independence from
the British in 1960 at the time owing to
previous centuries of both Ottoman and
Greek influence on the island Cyprus was
an ethnically mixed Society where about
78% of the total population were Greeks
and another 18% of the population were
Turks a very convoluted government was
set up by the British and Post
Independent Cyprus that was designed to
try and enable the Greeks and the Turks
on the island to share power but it
really just ultimately led to conflict
between them instead at the time the
Greeks of Cyprus generally favored a
full Union and annexation of the entire
island with Greece while the Turks of
Cyprus generally favored a partition of
the island with the more Turkish
majority northern areas separating and
potentially joining with turkey but both
of these Concepts were firmly rejected
by both the UK and turkey alike and so
cyprus's original Constitution was
drafted by all of them as a sort of
compromise to explain icly forbid Cyprus
from either joining Greece or
partitioning itself in half intended to
keep Cyprus both whole and non-aligned
regardless ethnic tensions on the island
between the Greek and Turkish
communities continued and eventually a
military hun government in Greece
sponsored a coup in Cyprus in 1974 that
installed a PR gree annexation
government into power on the island
which turkey flatly rejected as a
violation of Greece's previous agreement
to do exactly not that and so then
turkey decided to launch an amphibious
invasion of Cypress shortly afterwards
that resulted in the Turkish Army coming
to occupy about the northern third of
the island that resulted in the mass
expulsion of ethnic Greeks from the
north to the south of the island and
ethnic Turks who were expelled from the
south to the north eventually the two
sides agreed on a ceasefire and the UN
set up a buffer zone across the entire
Island that has kept the Greek and
Turkish communities on Cypress separated
by a wall in soldiers ever since years
later in 1983 the Turkish occupied area
of Northern Cyprus unilaterally declared
their independence from the Republic of
Cyprus as the trnc which to date has
only ever been legally recognized as an
independent country by turkey itself
while the Republic of Cyprus has
continually maintained that that
Declaration was illegal and continues to
claim all of the TRN C's control
territory and since turkey's 1974
Invasion they've made the situation even
more controversial by allowing tens of
thousand thousands of Turkish settlers
from the mainland to move into the trnc
so many so that currently it's estimated
that about half of the tnc's total
population today in 2024 are made up of
Turkish settlers or their descendants
who are new to the island since
1974 this is a hugely controversial
issue within both the Republic of Cyprus
and Greece who each reject the trc's
unilateral Independence declaration and
who also both maintained that in order
to finally resolve the Cypress dispute
all or at least most of the Turkish
settlers and their descendants who have
moved to the island since
1974 have to be expelled which the Turks
refus because that would probably be
half of the TRN C's population and
result in a huge Refugee exitus back to
Turkey this is also a huge part of why a
referendum on reunification hosted
across Cyprus in 2004 had such radically
different voting patterns between the
Turks and the Greeks on the island were
65% of Turks on the island voted in
favor of reunification while 76% of
Greeks on the island rejected
reunification largely because the terms
of the reunification referendum in 2004
did not include an expulsion of any of
the post 1974 Turkish settlers almost
immediately after that referendum the
Republic of Cyprus was formally admitted
into the European Union and ever since
the north of the island has been
considered to be the only part of EU
territory that's under foreign military
occupation all negotiations on the
reunification of Cyprus have failed ever
since owing to the Greeks opposition to
the status of Turkish settlers and the
Turks fears of a tyranny by the majority
and a potential ethnic cleansing and so
the island has remained de facto divided
with the UN still patrolling the border
between them and the Turkish military
still remaining present in the north and
with the South maintaining its claim to
all of the north recognized by virtually
all of the International Community and
the North asserting its independence
only recognized by turkey the dispute
over the status of Cyprus also extends
out into the maritime theater as well
turkey maintains a very unique argument
in international maritime law which
asserts that no Islands including Cyprus
can be entitled to the usual 200
nautical mile EZ ascribed to states by
International un maritime law turkey's
unique legal view is that islands should
only be entitled to 12 nautical
territorial Waters and no EZ while EZ's
should only be granted to Continental
Coastal territories based on that
argument and belief turkey's claimed e
in the Eastern Mediterranean looks like
this while cyprus's e claimed that's
based on the un's laws looks like this
which leads to a huge Maritime area
around Cypress claimed by both Cypress
and turkey alike moreover the trnc also
claims for itself this huge e EZ area
that looks like this which leads to
another huge overlapping area of
Maritime claims between the Republic of
Cyprus and the trnc which has gotten in
even more contentious recently as major
natural gas Fields have been discovered
in the area since the 2010s and turkey
has begun drilling from more natural gas
within the waters they dispute with
Cyprus leading to frequent clashes
between the cypriate and Turkish
governments and the International
Community and it's not even the only
large and strategically important
Maritime dispute maintained by turkey
because they have an even bigger and
even more controversial Maritime dispute
with their neighbor Greece within the
aan sea because the UN Grant States the
right to territorial Waters up to 12
nautical miles from all of their
coastlines and because Greece has so
many islands dotted all throughout the
aan if Greece applied the customary 12
nautical mile rule here they would
effectively come to possess the entire
aan as a great dominated territorial sea
that would heavily restrict turkey's aan
Coastline from access to international
waters which turkey has for decades
argued as unfair in the interest of
equity instead turkey has effectively
pressured the Greeks into a status quo
arrangement in the aan where both sides
only recognize a six nautical mile limit
of territorial Waters instead of the
more customary 12 nautical miles that
looks like this while turkey has
frequently threatened war with Greece
over the decades if they ever decide to
to unilaterally extend their territorial
Waters in The aan up to the UN
recognized 12 nautical mile limits the
dispute also extends out from
territorial Waters into an e dispute as
well remember the turkey uniquely argues
that Islands cannot have their own EZ
areas and only Continental land masses
can have them instead which leads turkey
to claim the eastern half of the aan sea
as its own EZ along the median line
between the Turkish and Greek mainlands
that ignores all of Greece's islands in
the aan as far as EZ claims go with
turkey only recognizing the islands
small six nautical mile territorial
Waters turkey views this policy as
something more fair that divides the aan
and its resources more evenly between
themselves in Greece and which also
gives them more breathing space while
Greece views it differently as a covert
Turkish attempt to ins Circle their
easternmost Islands some of which are
heavily populated like roads lesos and
chos which would all be much harder to
defend during a wartime scenario if
surrounded by Turkish Waters turkey
argues that tiny Greek controlled
islands like Castell orizo that barely
have a population of more than 500
people shouldn't be entitled to a huge e
area like this that blocks off the
Turkish Mainland and so you ultimately
have a huge area of the aanc and the
Eastern Mediterranean that are hotly
disputed between Greece who claims
themselves an e based on the US 's rules
that enable Islands to have full ezs and
turkey who uniquely claims that Islands
cannot possess ezs and that ezs can only
be determined by Continental land masses
and then we arrive at all of the various
territorial disputes across the former
Soviet Union of which there are very
very many in mdova there's a narrow
strip of land that follows between the
denester river in the west and the
border with Ukraine in the East that is
de facto under the control of an entity
that calls itself transnistria which is
disputed and claimed entirely by the
government of Moldova mdova used to be a
Soviet Republic and when the Soviet
Union was collapsing in 1991 the region
of transnistria which had a High
ethnically mixed population of Russians
movans and ukrainians unilaterally
declared their independence from mova
with the intention of trying to remain
within the Soviet Union and later within
Russia a brief 3-month long war was
fought between them in 1992 that saw
Russia directly supporting the trans
transnistrian side in which a few
hundred people were killed before a
ceasefire was agreed upon that kept
transnistria deao independent but
legally unrecognized by any other
country in the world a situation that
remains unresolved and Frozen to this
day there's a little over 360,000 people
who live within transnistria today and
Russia has maintained a permanent troop
deployment of around 1,500 soldiers to
the territory which led to the Council
of Europe ruling in 2022 the
transnistria was legally movan territory
under Russian military occupation and
that of course is not the only territory
to have fallen under that classification
recently as the Soviet Union was
disintegrating in the 1990s two ethnic
minorities in the Soviet Republic of
Georgia the amca and the oans began
fighting against the Georgian government
for their own independence as well they
were both directly supported by the
Russian government that resulted in both
of their deao independences the war in
abazia across 1992 and '93 was
especially brutal with as many as 30,000
people killed throughout the conflict
and severe human rights abuses that were
perpetrated by every site involved and
ended with a mass ethnic cleansing
campaign of the territory's ethnic
Georgians that saw around
250,000 of them get expelled out of
abazia into the rest of Georgia later in
2008 fighting between these separatist
controlled regions and the Georgian
government flared up one once again
which led to the Russian army launching
a fullscale invasion of Georgia that saw
the entirety of abazia and South oia
both falling under Russian military
occupation or protection depending on
your point of view again with Russia
harking back to the precedent set by
NATO's intervention into Kosovo against
Serbia to justify its own intervention
into abazia and South oia against
Georgia Russia has since gone on to
legally recognize abazia and South oia's
Independence has established military
bases throughout both of them and has
increasingly integrated both territories
ever closer to Russia both economically
and politically which has led to Georgia
along with the EU turkey Ukraine the US
UK Canada Australia China Japan and the
UN to all formally classify the
territories as being under Russian
military occupation which represents
roughly 20% of Georgia's internationally
recognized territory as under Russian
occupation and then of course the 2008
Russian invasion and occupation of about
20% of Georgia's internationally
recognized territory seems almost like a
dress rehearsal in hindsight for what
would later come to Ukraine which is
indisputably the site of the most
controversial territorial dispute in
Europe today and probably in the entire
world in 2014 Russia invaded the
territories of Crimea and Sebastapol and
unilaterally Annex them both into Russia
which has been disputed by Ukraine and
most of the International Community for
the past decade ever since and then in
2022 Russia launched an allout military
invasion of Ukraine that is continuing
more than 2 and 1/2 years later since
that Invasion Russia has gone on to
unilaterally declare the annexations of
four additional entire Ukrainian
provinces as well luhansk Donetsk zapia
and hiran which together with Crimea and
Sebastapol represent roughly 20% of
Ukraine's internationally recognized
territory about the same size as Austria
the that Russia all claims for itself
and that was all home to a pre-war
population of nearly 12 million people a
massive area and population disputed
between them recent official Russian
government issued Maps show all of these
territories as fully belonging to Russia
and Russia's currently stated War
objectives in Ukraine are to secure all
of their full control but as it
currently stands there are still
significant amounts of the donet zapia
and hiran provinces that still remained
under Ukrainian control and that the
Russians are still attempting to conquer
and so far Ukraine has not surrendered
or compromised and continues to claim
all of these territories overran by
Russia since 2014 including Crimea
adding up both sides' losses together
since the invasion of 2022 began it's
currently estimated that more than 1
million soldiers have been killed or
wounded by the war over these
territories while tens of thousands of
Ukrainian civilians have also been
killed at a minimum while more than 6
million ukrainians are also believed to
have fled the country due to the
fighting since 20202 all of which has
marked the deadliest and largest scale
conflict in Europe seen since the second
world war and the largest Refugee crisis
seen globally during the entire 21st
century all of which makes the disputed
territories in Ukraine arguably the most
controversial and deadliest in the
entire world today all in all the these
are all of the territories across Europe
that are currently disputed as of today
in
2024 but there are many other
territories that might fall into
disputes in the future and many others
that have only very recently been
tenuously resolved most of the
territories in eastern Ukraine outside
of small pro-russian separatist areas in
donet and luhansk were not openly in
dispute until they very suddenly were
starting in 2022 and more than a million
people have been killed and injured
fighting over them since then
territorial disputes are often fluid and
can both end and begin very suddenly and
one of the most recently resolved major
territorial disputes on the continent
that has the potential to flare back up
again in the future concerns the status
of Northern Ireland a part of the United
Kingdom that for decades up until very
recently in 1998 was wholly claimed and
disputed by the Republic of Ireland's
government leading up to that point for
about three decades between the 1960s
and the end of the 1990s the political
status and future of Northern Ireland as
a part of the United Kingdom triggered
one of modern Europe's longest running
insurgencies and violent conflicts in
which thousands of people were killed
and tens of thousands of others were
wounded many with life-altering
debilitating injuries the conflict was
waged between Irish Republican
paramilitaries like the IRA who wanted
to see Northern Ireland leave the UK and
join with the Republic of Ireland and
Loyalist and unionist Par militaries
along with the British State security
forces who wanted to maintain Northern
Ireland's British status the conflict
involved major assassination attempts on
members of the British royal family and
even the British prime minister the
largest bombing seen in burden since the
second world war and an often times
heavy-handed British counterinsurgency
campaign that led to brutal incidents
like Bloody Sunday in which British
soldiers shot into an unarmed crowd of
Irish protesters and killed 14 of them
and never faced any legal
consequences the whole history of the
Northern Ireland conflict often referred
to as the troubles is vital to
understanding the context that led to
the Good Friday agreement in 1998 when
the Republic of Ireland finally agreed
to renounce its territorial claim to
Northern Ireland and why the questions
over Northern Ireland's ultimate status
have begun to return back to the
international stage again today in the
2020s in a post brexit world where the
UK has withdrawn from the Europe Union
and taken Northern Ireland along with it
since then Catholics in Northern Ireland
for the very first time in the
territories entire history became a
demographically larger group than
Protestants in 2021 and earlier in 2024
Michelle O'Neal made history when she
became the first ever Irish nationalist
to be elected as Northern Ireland's
first Minister and she is since stated
that she fully expects a referendum on
Northern Ireland's reunification with
the Republic of of Ireland to be hosted
sometime within the next decade
understanding the events that took place
during the troubles in Northern Ireland
is critically important to understanding
the context of what's taking place in
Northern Ireland the UK and in Europe
today but at the same time we all know
that if I made a very in-depth video
covering the troubles the many many
disturbing violent and inherently
controversial details of discussing a
subject that crosses the line into
recent incidents of terrorism massacres
would without a doubt cause the entire
video to become demonetized and age
restricted which I actually agree with
and think is very appropriate but it
also ultimately means that YouTube's
algorithm which is designed to show you
appropriate videos alongside of ads in
order to make money would never actually
promote the video to you in your feed
which means that there's just simply no
way that you would ever see it here on
this site at all and that's why instead
I created yet another fulllength
companion video to this one in my
ongoing modern conflict series that
covers to the best of my ability the
entire course of events and explanation
into what took place throughout the
period of the troubles in Northern
Ireland involving now Infamous
organizations like the Irish Republican
Army or the IRA and I uploaded it
directly to nebula where you can go and
watch it right now as I'm sure you've
probably already heard by now nebula is
the home of tons of exclusive adree
content like my entire modern conflict
series with more than 30 other
fulllength exclusive videos over there
that you can go and watch right now
covering dozens of recent major Wars and
conflicts that'll help you stay up
todate on what's going on across our
world and why from all of these videos
covering the ongoing Russian invasion of
Ukraine to these other episodes covering
Russia's other Wars in Georgia Chia and
transnistria to this massive episode
covering the collapse of Yugoslavia and
many many others with brand new episodes
releasing every single month and even
better I also recently started another
completely new monthly series on nebula
called war room which will track all of
the latest breaking geopolitical news
developing from conflicts around the
world and break them down into a single
easily digestible monthly video briefing
series that'll help you stay even more
up Tod dat and informed on what's
currently happening around the world and
why the latest episode in war room
covering all of the breaking
geopolitical news and developments from
last last month in September including
Israel's war on Hezbollah and their
bombing campaign in Lebanon is live on
nebula for you to go and watch right now
and new episodes will be released every
single month just like the monthly new
episodes in modern conflicts Aban
meaning two new exclusive real life L
videos on nebula that you won't find on
YouTube going out every month going
forward and what's even more you also
get access to all of the other amazing
exclusive content that's on nebula
because the best part about this this
site is that it's jointly co-owned by
all of its creators built by me and
hundreds of other independent YouTubers
and podcasters and because it's a
subscription based service we all get to
work on way bigger and higher budget
Productions over there than we could
ever do on our own on YouTube that's why
there's tons of other exclusive content
that you'll find equally fascinating
from all of these other creators over
there you probably also already know as
well and best of all if you sign up by
clicking the button that's here on your
screen right now or scan the QR codee or
by following the link Down Below in the
description you'll receive an insane 40%
discount off of an annual subscription
which means that it'll only cost you $3
a month or $36 a year for all of this
awesome exclusive content from myself
and hundreds of other independent
creators with even more stuff getting
added every single month it's the
absolute best way to help support what
I'm doing here on real life lore and as
always thank you so much for watching